[Music]
what's up party people we are talking
about encanto today please do talk about
encounter no no no um that song's been
stuck in my head uh since i heard it
which was coming up on like three four
months ago and boy or is my brain tired
well you've got a you've got a small
you've got a child of encanto age i have
a child yeah this was the first movie
she sat through start to finish like i
tried to like make her watch you know
blade runner and stuff like that as a
baby but she would lose interest this is
the first one where she's been like okay
i'm locked in uh i'm on this journey
with mirabelle and because of that uh
it's the soundtrack of my life
because
one song has replaced the next one we're
now kind of moving into you know the
kind of mid-tier in kanto songs
you've gotten through surface pressure
in bruno and yeah that's like
yeah family madrigal and failed magical
was actually number one and i i think
that's still my favorite song um but
it's the the sisters one that's kind of
pop punky anyways we don't need to talk
about it we're here to talk about it
sure
this is a film that despite all this i
do really like uh yeah i i like this
movie a lot um
i'm so glad that uh uh i didn't get
trapped in the frozen generation and
this has been uh the movie that haunts
me because i really do like this one
um
it despite suffering from i think some
sort of
ambiguous plotting of like it's kind of
a vague like we have to save a miracle
and go on this adventure where we're
actually not really going to leave the
house like
the plot goals are a little bit big but
i don't care it doesn't mean i'm an
adult i don't need like a ton of action
or like a big macguffin at the center of
it all i thought that this was actually
a really good exploration of family
dynamics and and the the hidden
pressures that everybody feels like
they're under and i don't know i i dug
it what about you lon yeah i totally
agree i i actually feel like this is
probably one of my favorite of the sort
of
disney animated musicals from after i
was already like a grown you know like
obviously i came up i was like 10 i
think when little mermaid came out in
theaters so that disney renaissance era
is always going to be the one that's
like the the most special to me because
i was a kid for it when those came out
but in the in the aftermath of that i
think this is one of the ones that's
really resonated the most for me that
i've seen as an adult and i think it's
it's it's specific in a way that a lot
of
kids movies and kids musicals you know
they've got themes but they've got nice
general
themes you know like help each other
sharing his character accept people who
are different from you great good things
but
this is a movie that really feels like
it there's a there's a real emotional
resonance to it it's dealing with things
like generational trauma and performance
anxiety and and uh you know being sort
of haunted by expectations that are
placed on you and like
really specific stuff that i think yeah
adult viewers are going to respond to
totally
um and you know it doesn't hurt that of
course it's like just kind of a given
these days that it's going to look great
like they have really
really stepped it up like
what's uh what stood up to me in this
one you know like moana it was the water
and um right this one it was uh the
dancing i feel like the choreography uh
was
incredible and lifelike and i've never
i've never really noticed the dancing in
a cartoon before it'd be like wow that
they're really like this could be on
stage and it would look great i agree
and this it's not the first like moana's
another one where they collaborated with
flynn manuel miranda on the songs but i
think one thing that he really brings to
this or that comes out in this it this
feels almost like an adaptation of a
stage musical and i know i've seen
people say that too like you could
completely conceive of how this would
work on broadway like oh if you do like
the harry potter treatment where like
you have some magic tricks going on with
the house and the stage director i mean
it is already kind of like one house of
this big cast that they're all in the
family and they've all got their little
you know their own magic gifts and it
does have that feeling it feels like a
broadway musical almost brought to life
through animation so yeah i think that
that very strongly and there are there's
like these ensemble big dance numbers in
the house is almost a a dancer along
with the company uh and yeah it does
have that vibe as opposed to a lot of
other disney musicals where it's like a
lot more solo songs or you know it's
stuff like elsa creating a frozen castle
while she sings let it go by herself and
this one has more of that yeah like it's
like seeing a big big musical number
with a lot of right worked out sort of
choreography and dance numbers yeah so
you know we dug it nothing not the real
that's the headline news to take away uh
and also i think on this one what was
very exciting is uh we got to do music
again
um yeah we've had to uh
we've had to
we were worried about uh music in the
future because our incredibly talented
uh songwriter composer who's back with
us as far back as um the michael bolton
stuff uh matt
um
has made the extremely unwise decision
to go to law school
[Laughter]
the money's in music
it's
[Applause]
youtube parody videos that's where the
culture is going yeah that's that's
where the cold hard cash is at yeah
uh through uh max dion um i don't know
exactly how they got hooked up but uh
but we found this uh guy blue
uh
not of not blue man group uh just simply
blue b-l-e-u um is a legit arranger
songwriter i think he teaches uh music
and composition and stuff like that and
it's just a super nice guy and fun to
work with and and i think knocked it out
of the park uh so get ready for more
music because now that's what all i
really want to be is weird al so i think
we're gonna see things slowly moving in
a weird al direction of just you me and
danielle all have that in common is that
we all really enjoy writing parody song
lyrics and like don't get enough
opportunity to do it as as of now so
yeah we're looking for any excuse did
you see the the set photos of daniel
radcliff as i did yeah i think it looks
good i think oh yeah no people were
people were sour on it it's like well
obviously it's not gonna be a one to one
like you're gonna have to use a little
bit of your imagination but no i thought
it's exactly what i want daniel
radcliffe has a weird album look like
yeah i can see it so uh check out blue
uh he's got like a he's got a legit like
pop album on spotify
i know his info is in the um
the honest trailer but maybe we can put
it in this commentary as well so get to
know blue because you'll be hearing uh
more of his stuff in the future i think
my boy yeah or or do it now because uh
you never know when these things will
get flagged and taken down because
there's nothing more litigious than a
music robot um
then we can bring back matt citron from
law school to be our music that's right
he'll defend us yeah yeah getting
avengers together all right let's watch
the trailer
[Music]
from the studio that colonized your
childhood comes the latest culture to
get strip mined by disney for anything
they can turn into movies merch or theme
parks but these days they've been doing
it respectfully with great characters
and catchy songs so truce
and canto
now pause uh
something disney did that we did not do
and apologies but that's uh uh
reach out or do any research about
colombia or colombian folklore or
anything like that
we gotta write one of these a week folks
they have years to work on these in
fairness to us
there was a time for fact-finding
missions to bogata well i was just i
wonder how much of this is pulled from
colombian folklore and how much was just
like set dressing i i'm genuinely
curious if you know in the comments like
what is uh part of that uh cultural
heritage and mythology and what's just
like they came up with for a disney
movie my my understanding of it was that
the
and i i again not personally i've read
about this and i i don't know this you
know innately but uh what i what i read
when the movie came out or whatever it's
the the story itself was sort of an
original story that they kind of worked
out it's not specifically one colombian
myth or legend or whatever but there are
a lot of little references culturally
in terms of folklore everything
sprinkled throughout so like a lot of
the food and the specific music and
dance references and the flower
arrangements and all of that stuff it's
really steeped in
specifics from colombian culture i mean
like yeah but not the story specifically
okay i mean the general vibe was like uh
you know hundred years of solitude he uh
gabriel garcia marquette he's a he's a
colombian guy i think um and it was like
the kind of magical realism
degenerational family but it's
definitely not a straight adaptation i
don't think there is like a colombian
like the story of the magic candle and
it's rooted in that specifically but yes
exactly what you're saying like there
are there are tons of sort of magical
realist south american kind of stories
that this is drawing on
well seemed fun seemed like a fun place
uh anyways keep playing turn to columbia
back in the nineteen something or others
and stay in the magical family's magic
casita a house that's always listening
the house isn't gonna decorate itself
sorry with a cousin who can hear a pin
drop no one has to know
i know a cousin who controls an army of
spies the rats told me everything and a
creepy uncle watching through the walls
how long have you been back here truly
the worst place on earth to be a teenage
girl and me teenage girl mirabelle the
family
it is extra sad um
when you think about uh
when you get your powers in this family
you don't just get the superpower you
get like a bat cave like a themed right
yeah you get like a themed awesome room
now the house can move and redecorate
and you know it's like a tardis it can
do whatever it wants
it's bigger on the inside but she still
has the most like bare bones like
there's some crayon on the walls i think
like a few of you don't have to live in
the nursery like she never gets to move
out of where the babies stay
that's messed up right it's super messed
up well here's what i i feel like all of
that would be okay it's kind of the like
you know kids stories often start with
the kid in a really miserable like harry
potter he's like eating fish heads and
living under the stairs so that he can
appreciate what comes next but we don't
end this confirming that mirabelle gets
to move out of the nursery like she as
far as we know still there she gets the
door but she gets the front door so i
think she just has like prima nocta like
she could just sleep in anybody's room
or maybe she's asleep in the living room
she's crashing out in the foyer like
that's still not i would i feel like
it's really weirdly missing a beat at
the end
where we finally see mirabe you see her
in a big four poster bed and grandma has
to sleep on the floor right and i feel
like well i do i think that's the issue
is that what they're sort of trying to
set up is she's going to be the new
abuela like she's going to be the
matriarch one day
she's now the source of the magic or the
one who has the closest connection to
the magic and i like all that i think
all that works but i still she needs a
bedroom like this is just not fit it's a
room
and it's it's all glasses themed or
something like come on give her
something this is cruel
uh okay keep going
aside from the standard disney power
that lets you freeze time
she'll battle high expectations
inadequacy and literal burnout
as she struggles to understand why she
wasn't granted a special gift though if
you ask me her gift is living rent-free
in a house that cleans itself while her
siblings get a lifetime sentence of
community service when they turn five
will you serve this community
mira you have it so easy let it go
that's what i'm always saying bro
smuggle a pin and pad into the theater
because there's so many characters in
this one even the characters can't keep
track of the characters wait who's
assistant who's a cousin there's so many
people how do you give them australia as
a magic candle gives three old
generations a super power until it ran
out of good ideas and started handing
out curses there's louisa who's super
strong great mom can heal the sick with
food awesome peppa's mood changes the
weather that's more like a punishment
though right you're lucky it's not a
hurricane antonio can talk to animals
which is cool until you hear your
friends eat your other friends don't eat
those
this guy can shape-shift what's that
good for crime yeah pause
i mean i just i kept thinking of like
what happened at the uh at the town you
know power reveal party when it's
revealed that you know this guy
is uh basically the monster from the
thing
[Laughter]
so he could like impersonate my husband
like
this one can um this one can control the
weather oh perfect always sunny in 70.
no no when she gets mad it's gonna be
blizzards
yeah it seems it seems like the the
shape-shifting one is just like well
this is sinister like i don't what's
even it useful for like they you could
feel them almost struggling like
they came up with one but you could be a
tall guy which is a small guy i need a
tall guy yeah is he like a one of the
wonder twins that can turn into like a
very large bucket of water no
it looks like it's just people it
doesn't look like he could become an
object they have this one moment where
like a mom he turns into a a mom uh and
and holds a baby while the real mom
takes a nap right that's just that's
very specific and very unsettling kind
of creepy yeah like i don't like that
baby doesn't know any better it thinks
that's it's like that's sinister like i
said it'd be like invisibility where at
first you'd be like oh nice thing about
wait a minute
yeah i mean if it's all in the context
of like this is to serve the town then
you really wonder where this candle is
is pulling these things from it that
that one more seems like uh keeping you
know the madrigal family's power in
place so that they have you know so they
can know what's going on a guy who can
create electricity and now your homes
have power that's a good one but they
could kill the mayor of the town and
then uh impersonate him yeah like
yeah we didn't we didn't we didn't come
up with a no no unlimited food she still
has to cook the food that heals people
well we can transform you into any
person you want to impersonate can
people eat flowers there are edible
flowers so maybe i guess
it's awesome that's just like pointless
like she can make flowers it's pretty
mine
i think you're a little too grumpy on
that like flowers are nice to have and
it's nice but it's not you're not
helping any like you're not doing
service for the community with them oh
if someone gave you flowers you wouldn't
say oh thank you like look i filled your
say i
that's what this town needs is like one
really crabby scottish guy one ogre he's
like flowers
oh
why am i in colombia
okay keep going
someone write that sketch
keep playing so you can have seconds
worth of shot delores has super hearing
in a house with two married couples
definite curse bruno can see the future
but mostly just the bad stuff big time
curse and isabella grows flowers come on
candle get your head out of your wax if
you can't think of anything useful just
magic up some birth control
there's that thing where it's like it's
kind of like the the dad in uh or prince
charming's dad in cinderella where she
like lets it drop like she's gonna have
five children yes yeah she is kind of
thinking of her own family as like
breeding stock but oh sure yeah yeah
there's definitely that
i would say too
there's like there's like a conventional
disney movie buried inside this one
where like they're marrying the daughter
off to a guy she doesn't really love
because it's good for the family and
like that used to just be the core guy
the whole movie disney movie and this
one it's like ah but she probably won't
end up with that guy we'll figure
something out
the house is the the issue here what
about the magic candle yeah in the span
of like one very sped up you know
hamilton style uh rap break in the final
song we can just we can tie up that uh
it's the sister and she's gonna
yeah that's right the guy doing the
voice of the boyfriend is maluma that
columbia pop star who's also
uh j lo's unfaithful husband in the
beginning of marry me on peacock oh
wow he's really happy about that
universe he's having a moment
all right keep playing
now it's up to mirabelle to discover why
and defeat the evil villain at the
center of it all not bruno he's just
lazy you know the mountains around the
encounter are pretty tall and uh like i
said free food and everything
no the real antagonist in this movie is
getting gaslit by your grandma the magic
is strong everything is fine there is
nothing wrong with la casa madrigal the
magic is strong and so are the drinks
not exactly jafar level evil but there's
something off about this abuela if that
is your real name
oh it is your real name just grandma in
spanish well that must have been hard to
grow up with
yeah enjoy a story i mean i like i don't
think this needed a you know a a demon
like some sort of like
evil
yeah evil animated monster to like some
lava thing to pop out and uh and them
all to unite captain planets although
now that i'm saying it that would be a
cool scene if they had to do like full
x-men
yeah i i liked it i thought that was a
nice aspect of it they're their own
they're literally their own worst enemy
their their crippling self-doubt is the
is the villain and uh i you know i i
like that and i thought they did find
clever ways to make it still feel like
an adventure like she has to go into
bruno's tower you know there there are
missions to accomplish even though
there's not like a you know calculating
disney villain behind the scenes
plotting their downfall i just think if
if mirabelle was like
like uh i guess it's mystique in the new
x-men movies like if it ended with her
like directing them to kind of form like
voltron like louisa attack okay and then
right and now peppa hit him with the
lightning
that'll be the sequel you got to save
something save it for the speaking or
that would be the ride when you go
through
the ride they'll have to all team up and
fight you know so the evil house down
the down
there's an evil family with a divergent
haunted house down the block and then
they're gonna be rhyme
uh all right keep going so enjoy a story
about complex emotions and long
simmering resentments then i'll get tied
up neatly in a few minutes talks api
it's a kids movie
and i hear you
but who cares when the colors are this
bright the dancing is this fluid and the
music is this catchy because lin-manuel
is keeping the hot streak alive with one
heart-rending oscar-nominated song and
three other jams that you'll be singing
for months like the magic powers that
gloss over serious issue song
[Music]
so pause um
we've uh we've changed the lyrics
obviously um but he's also true he's
also changed the uh the tempo and the
key and a few other things and we're
hoping we're hoping that's enough to not
get uh flagged or demonetized or
whatever it's obvious what we're
parodying but it doesn't sound exactly
the same that is the fine line we have
yet to discover because you know they
don't take the trailer down per se but
they do we can get copyright we have
gotten copyright strikes and like it's
clearly covered under parody law like if
we went to court we would win but we're
not going to go to court over no we're
not going to go internationally so it's
and youtube you know you're you are
totally guilty until proven innocent
when it comes to like right issues i
want to see that you know those like
that like dark water all those ways that
like the lawyer who takes the impossible
case against the mega corporation like a
civil action where's the one about the
lawyer who represents like the small
youtube channel against the enormous
media company you know i want that to be
the next season of perry mason yeah
i just really want like mark ruffalo to
like
play a guy who's like they're kids songs
kids this is clearly fair use
uh yeah ryan says law and order new
media yeah where is that yeah where's
where's jack
help defend us
keep playing
now
[Music]
if she's repressed imagine how i feel
mom what this family means
pause
something i i actually i'm surprised i
don't get because i've seen this movie
like seven times um
the dad
keeps getting stung by bees why is his
face always puffed up
is he just like winnie the pooh he like
can't keep his head out of the honey
out of a hornet's nest i think instead
he doesn't have to be careful because
his wife can just heal him oh okay so
that's why he's just blundering into the
stuff he's allergic to exactly he's not
careful because she could always just
like eat up you know whatever those
those and whatever
snacks she's making for him and uh so
when she you know when they lose their
powers or whatever like he's not he's
thrown off i think that's the idea
wow i mean
is that like an eternal life situation
for the entire town are they is it
actually 2050 when they leave the
encounter and they've just been kept
alive by magic
oh i i yeah i don't know i don't know
how the healing factor of the food works
like if it's if it's are you being made
younger or it's just healing if you have
a a problem right
uh enkento ii yeah that'll all right all
of this will be explored in kanto too
the search for more powers more money
yeah all right keep going
more
[Music]
family needs all cantons therapy
oh crap the lin manuel is trying to tell
us something song
[Music]
a nice graphic work kevin yeah
[Music]
but he can't take a break
[Music]
money's great
well okay let's pause let's discuss lynn
uh where we're at in the lynn manuel
miranda sons i feel like the miranda
sons has passed he was so he was
overrated post hamilton and now he's
underrated post i think in kanto and um
uh tick boom he had four
musicals last year right because there
was also that one
uh what was it what was it called the
vevo
yeah the series or something no that was
a it was another movie yeah and then
there was one more two i'm gonna look it
up but like so he's yeah he is like
non-stop just killing it constantly
we've gotten too much it was in the
heights
you know you've reached peak lynn when
there was like a documentary about the
improv uh improv group
in college yeah yeah
i don't need to know any of this um but
i do think uh uh this is um i think some
of disney's best music you know it's up
there in the in the best uh music of the
last 10 years for me and then um i think
tic-tic boom was fantastic um
and he i think he he kept himself out of
it no no cameo i don't remember seeing
him no it's like every single other
broadway person yeah yeah which was
fascinating um so yeah that's that's
where i'm at in my mid-manual journey
it's impossible like after you do
something that is like hamilton's size
like so few things ever get to be
hamilton's eyes that once you've done
something like that like that's it
you'll know like it doesn't matter it's
not even a testament to the quality of
anything else he's ever done like
nothing you ever do is gonna have that
because it can't you already broke
through and had your hamilton moment so
it's always going to be he's going to
live in that in that shadow forever no
matter how good the follow-up
work is about how many other presidents
could could wrap
just
just like van buren who's to say yeah
the the millard fillmore rap musical
right around the corner but it's like i
mean even like spielberg like to this
day when spielberg does like a movie
that you don't associate with like
family sci-fi people like oh from
spielberg and it's like you guys make
that
like
every genre
in the world we just still think of et
because that's you know we're still
making e.t um
and yeah just different kids on
different bikes we call it yeah
it's a decoration it's a whole different
video all right keep playing song that
you'll not be named
please don't start singing
no god no no
we can't stop singing
[Music]
it begins in my head not
[Music]
this one's definitely an autobiography
oh yes
[Music]
it just tells you like all you need is a
hook because uh and even blue said as
much he's like the song isn't very
good as in like complex or interesting
musically it's really like a like songs
are like a b a b c d like different
sections and stuff like that it's just
like slight variations on a over and
over and over again
and man
it just gets there and brew no no no is
um really an ear worm uh
there was a story about how
he i think his name was oscar in in
early drafts of the script but
lin-manuel asked to change it for that
chorus like that if he could have a no
at the end of his name to make that song
really work and they were like yep okay
and history
yeah
yeah wait for it let him do it uh
yeah no
it's interesting because it's not
usually the kind of song from the
musical that takes off you know it's not
the like character singing about what
they wish song or it's not the big love
ballad it's like the the work saw like
here's well you know here's the story
and it's the villain song which is never
the biggest one from the soundtrack
right and so uh it's interesting that
it's because purely on the strength of
the catchiness of that and clearly they
didn't expect that because that's not
the one they nominated for the awesome
that there i i was there's a there's a
fascinating bunch of conversation but
because the thing i think is most
interesting is in the 90s disney used to
just submit a bunch of different songs
and they would they would compete
against each other like when in the year
you know can you feel the love tonight
was nominated circle of life was
dominated you know like they would they
would
do multiples and now they're afraid of
cannibalizing themselves so they just
pick one and the
prevailing wisdom is you got to pick a
song that like in a quick clip people
are going to get here's how it relates
to like the themes of the movie and like
here's why this is a good song not just
as a song but like from this movie so
like i think that's over estimating the
amount of thought that academy voters
give these things because i think
they'll be like oh i i've heard of
bruno's like yeah i've heard right
well they also they had to do this
before they submitted before they knew
bruno was going to be this huge hit but
like i guess bruno the idea was oh it's
so tied up in the story of the movie
whereas those sort of guitars is just
like well it's kind of it's a nice song
about the themes of the movie it's in
spanish and so it feels more like on
point for income yeah
uh we will see if that uh if they win i
feel like there's this will be like uh
when they give them like the the actor
the award for the movie that didn't
deserve it but they like their whole
careers work that'll be why this one
it's not that do sorry this is a bad
song but i mean i feel like right this
will be the one people want and kanto to
win because yeah you know they want the
whole soundtrack to win right it's just
it is up against like billy eilish and
beyonce and like there's a lot of
competition this season but uh
interesting yeah we'll see
tune in to the oscars must see tv can't
can't miss it uh we'll we'll be we'll be
covering we'll be on twitter within two
minutes we'll be covering it minimally
if i have anything
[Music]
it's fun to do like a roast of it but i
don't know we'll see well tell us in the
comments how much oscars content you
want yeah uh all right keep playing
i haven't seen drive my car singing
oh yeah
story
no door of the explorer
luigi's mansion
the wrong kid
the changeling
no fart goes unheard where video game
turkey legs come from
gail weathers
jose exotic
another easy paycheck for alan tudyk and
it just didn't go this long to realize
capybaras are adorable hello
haunted by your tragic past mansion
what does disney have against bruno's
your blues
bruno
um it was a great catch i did not
remember there was another disney bruno
uh uh yeah i think kevin caught that
with the dog yeah yeah i was i
remembered celeb you know i brought up
celencio bruno but not
and that was also it was that was
cinderella right where that dog was
bruno and that looks like another movie
with a swarm of very helpful rats um
disney pro rat um and mouse i guess uh
pro rodent railroad definitely in the
kitchen ratatouille yeah exactly
delicious uh give me give me a one two
three of uh encanto
luca
seoul
i think those are just three encounter
one soul to luca three that's my list
and actually i would say moana was i
think the first time i read about this
where like disney and pixar artists
started like working together more like
disney disney screened an early version
of it for pixar and it was pixar artists
who gave them like here like do more the
water coming to life stuff is so good do
more of that and there's also a pixar
person's idea it'll do all of the uh the
rocks tattoos in 2d
and so after that they've started like
mixing it up and like collaborating
earlier in the process and i feel like
you can really tell in the disney movies
that like pixar people are giving them
ideas like it does feel like disney has
kind of integrated more of the pixar
style and the more recent stuff
well they're doing great work on the
kids side of things there's nothing to
uh have a serious meeting about um star
wars on the other hand well
there's like a 17 alarm fire at all
times uh that's really what i want to
talk about this week
we'll have to wait wait a little bit do
it a little bit this needs more colorful
vespas i think obviously
why don't why doesn't every modern doll
have a colored vest but imagine
oh it's the mods the mods are coming
i'll drive in on vespas
uh what this needs is a rancor um to
tear down the house to protect the house
uh let's talk about deleted scenes uh i
think we have a few let's check it out
starring
begonia nine-nine
adorable
dudley do right
the property mothers the perks of being
a wall brother
the pest the incredible bulk
donkey kong
judy bloom
blossom
petals to the metal influenza
poser
kid chameleon
loki loki
ma milo dammit man i'm a traditional
healer not a doctor
cloudy with a chance of downfalls
toddler doolittle the listen lady
we here for you
what's her room like an ear canal
23 and mirabelle
miss madrigal's home for peculiar
children
this is easily disney's best story about
being the only one in the group without
superpowers since hawkeye ended a few
weeks ago just pick up a bow mirror bell
learn to flip quarters you'll be fine
yeah little weird bit of synchronicity
there that yeah these two things came
out so close to each other all the
stories about the people without powers
for tv
save it for 2022. cheaper it's cheaper
this way
uh there's also a line that got cut that
was like um how cool it was to see like
oh she's like a short latino with curly
hair and glasses is like that's like our
disney heroine that we get and
everyone's like
this one's a dud she's a dad like what's
special about her
yeah clearly something's off like she's
not doing it uh we gotta find out what
uh makes this person uh good and unique
explain yourself
justify
why are you even here yeah
um so there you go uh let's move on to
some great
questions that you guys have been
submitting as we've been talking uh this
was hard i will just say this was a
really hard one i think to write because
i like the movie so much and i think
yeah i would say everything felt like a
nitpick to me yeah that's that's kind of
the deal with um
disney and i guess especially pixar
stuff and now i guess disney pixar is
uh they're good number one and number
two they're for children so it's not
like um you struck the same rib twice
but you made two distinct times yeah for
this one
even more so they we've done a few other
like pixary kind of stuff recently and
this one was really like full of teeth i
was just like oh but it's delightful
yeah what do you want from me i think i
have a small child trying to get into
this room you can come in if you want
but i am recording it's fine
if it happens
got some stuff to add
uh let's let's take some questions uh
evan j pretzer asks uh silly slash
bragging question for you i'm in
minneapolis for an interview where i
will likely become a us permanent
resident after moving from canada that's
a great downgrade but congratulations i
guess welcome to america welcome to
america uh what's the best immigrant
movie
oh wow i mean final the f the five volt
yes in america
america a great immigration immigration
story this i live um this is where i
became a a sercia head um
brooklyn uh
[Music]
uh i love that uh very very sweet
i would i would pick uh another fairly
recent one that i really enjoyed uh seth
rogen's an american pickle it's on uh
that was unexpectedly nice yeah i wanted
it to be uh like a dumber comedy but it
ended up being sweet and that's that's
fine too yeah i did right exactly and
also uh minari a few a few years ago
yeah oscar nominee minari another great
recent immigration story um so there you
go uh welcome to america uh you're in
minneapolis i think they have culverts
there that's probably the best food they
they are yeah it's very good they put
butter on their burger buns yeah it's
delicious
um all right uh anika bar asks which
region slash country slash culture
should get the disney treatment next
what would disney's version of germany
look like i don't i don't know enough
about germany like
just disco dancing i feel like i don't
know have we never i mean a lot of those
classic disney like grim
brothers
more than enough for you yeah bastard uh
i don't know um i mean i feel like
there's probably a lot of african
cultures that we've never even touched
in an american
family film that would be a fascinating
place to start right like there's not
like lion king is probably the closest
we've gotten in it's
you know they're lying yes yes
maybe like iceland like the the you know
the fairies and the
waterfall that would look pretty right
i'm sure there's a lot of icelandic
folklore and fairy tale stuff but i mean
i guess you get like this dreamworks how
to train your dragon is like
scandinavian nordic folklore but sure
mexico already got coco which in mexico
pretty reasonable just pausing on a
moment like this is just an interesting
thing about pop culture today because
back in my day uh it was like oh
you're
disney is turning your culture into a
into into a cartoon like this is
offensive and bad just on it on the
surface like you don't want uh
disney to do this and now it's like why
hasn't disney done my heritage
they did we mentioned it earlier though
it's the fact that they are now
collaborating with people from those
cultures
exactly it's not like mulan or
pocahontas where they're like pick one
you know throw a dart at a globe and
then they're like let's make up some
nonsense about this country now you know
like aladdin is like
semi-offensive because there weren't
really a lot of people with a background
in arabic folklore i mean agrabah is not
historically accurate right like i don't
even want to get into some of the stuff
they've had to remove from that movie
over the years but that's the problem is
that you'd hope today
they would be more respectful and rooted
in real stuff from that culture rather
than art
stereotypes let's see moving on um
uh sergio hernandez and adam halbert
both had questions about how uh uh
annoyed slash or happy i am that uh my
kid is definitely into this movie as
opposed to something like frozen or
whatever and you know i'm down i think
that of all the things you could grow up
with like mirabelle is a good
modern disney heroine where it's like
like her and moana i think would both be
and and like elsa as far as role models
i guess now elsa is kind of weird now i
like this one i'm i'm glad she's uh uh
she's a mirabelle over a um over a
frozen
uh and it's amazing like you know and
you've said this before long but i
almost didn't believe you where it's
like you show a kid
old school animation and they just you
know they'll watch it for a little bit
but if you show them like the 3d like
pixar or even live action lion king
stuff it's like
you know that they're absolutely wrapped
with attention so um i i try yelling at
her that she has poor taste but it
doesn't seem to stick
it's amazing how that how you don't get
to pick it up
classics yeah
uh all right oscar breach s uh what
historically what composer has written
the best foray of songs for multiple
disney films lin-manuel miranda robert
lopez alan menken sherman brothers randy
newman
wow that's tough i mean my heart says
randy newman but my head's it's got to
be menken i mean
i i said this before
because i came of age in the disney
renaissance era to me those are the
classics so yeah it's it's it's going to
be ashman menken and the the lion king
the little merm i guess the blind king
was after but the the the beauty and the
beast aladdin little mermaid pocket to
me is like the peak of all of it yeah
and there's that there's that incredible
howard ashman uh documentary on disney
plus that i highly recommend uh and
there's a part where he and men could go
in to jeffrey katzenberg's office and
basically are like we want to do aladdin
and they play like three whole songs
they're like they wrote prince ali
already and they're like here it is and
he's like no i don't like it go make
beauty and the beast instead it's like
how do you
what like the idea that those guys would
come to your office play prince ali be
like let us make this movie and you'd be
like nah prince ali is not the best song
on the latin soundtrack by far it was
but they they would they had like three
written it was like whole new world
prince
you had never had a friend like me or
something but if they're like listen to
this
all right i gotta go it's like a funny
robin williams type genie saying that
you'd buy that movie
i don't know i don't know what the hell
you're talking about but um
i mean i think you could you could
definitely make it like the sherman
brothers it's really hard to say it's
not that because so many of the classics
were yeah and like those songs you still
hear piped into disneyland every time
you go
uh so i don't i don't know it's personal
prep totally uh speaking music a lot of
people are very happy we're doing uh
music again and um are asking if we will
do full versions of the song i want to
do full versions there's no reason why
we can't we just have no i guess we
could just put them as youtube videos on
screen junkies it's gonna say we have no
outlet for it like i guess we could just
post them on so we're not a youtube
channel modify use baby well you know
i guess if we make the music fit yeah
you know we're going right to peacock
folks yeah look for him on pica yeah
well like i said this has inspired us to
maybe do some more uh music stuff um we
wrote a lot we wrote a lot of lyrics
that did not even get turned into songs
but that yeah i mean every we could go
back to the old uh to some of the older
trailers where we do have you know more
than we put in there so yeah um and
trust us as you can see from the deleted
scenes there's gold in them hills it's
all gold everything we cut is brilliant
uh that said um
next week something that i wish we had
time to make a uh a theme song for
wait you got have you gotten to their
eventually they i i saw joe's comment
that there are no lyrics to the theater
they sort of are they they do introduce
them eventually yeah they're very
straightforward lyrics but they are
lyrics yeah so everybody uh next week
get ready to take a bath
and crack open a uh
a whole new adventure on uh in the
farthest distant most central most
important parts of the galaxy
next week uh on our show commentaries
thanks for watching we'll see you then
bye
[Music]
you